okay you need to see this really quick
during the recent ceasefire between
Israel and Hamas Israel released 240
Palestinians from prison but this is
what's crazy that same week they also
arrested
133 Palestinians this is what a lot of
people don't really understand about the
Israeli occupation is that one of the
most egregious things that Israel does
is that they just arrest Palestinians
without charging them with a crime a lot
of these Palestinians are like teenage
boys who are arrested for like
effectively throwing stones since the
terrorist attack of October 7th Israel
has been going nuts on arresting people
in the West Bank which is different than
Gaza where Hamas is they've detained
over 3,000 Palestinians in the West Bank
which is 10 times the number of people
that they've released these people don't
know why they're arrested they will
never have a trial like this is not due
process this is not the rule of law this
is occupation it's wrong many of these
kids are going to be in prison for
months or years if you want to better
understand global politics follow along
for more